wassim qu'elle sera d'abord l'impact
militaire de ce retrait déjà il faut
rappeler que cette articulation a
démarré en juillet 2021 donc avec la
france qui quittent les bases du
nord-mali et s'était affiché très
clairement qu'ils auront un
redéploiement vers le niger maintenant
effectivement ça a été accélérée à cause
des autorités maliennes y aura un impact
réel sur le terrain parce que du moment
où la france se retire il les groupes
jihadistes ont une marge de manoeuvre
beaucoup plus importante mais la
question qui reste est ce que l'aviation
française aura accès à l'espace aérien
maliens ou pas parce que l'aviation
française même si l'arrêt française
n'est plus agi au profit des femmes a
donc des forces armées maliennes mais
aussi au profit des forces onusiennes à
présent thomas dit donc drones et
d'avions de chasse avions deux
interceptions donc ça c'est une question
qui est qui et qui reste en suspens pour
le moment peut-être vous mettre une
carte ont donc vous parler pour que l'on
comprenne bien où ça si tu es très bien
et donc évidemment les mouvements
jihadistes ont une marge de manoeuvre
plus importante mais la france est juste
à côté on va dire au niger au burkina
comme ça a été rappelé dans le sujet et
une opération assez importante juste
après il faut rappeler aussi qu'il ya eu
un premier but des contres les forces
françaises au nord du burkina quatre
militaires français blessés forces
spéciales dont un très gravement par la
même unité qui a été ciblé d'ailleurs et
qui avait causé la tacc et digne at a
aussi donc une grande attaque contre
l'armée contre l'armée burkinabè donc la
france reste reste présente mais
peut-être y aura un effet aussi on va
dire peut-être inattendue de ce départ
parce qu'il faut se rappeler aussi que
les autorités maliennes souhaite
négocier avec les djihadistes d'al qaïda
les djihadistes d'al qaïda ont mais
comme préambule à cela le départ des
armées françaises et et de la minus main
et le facteur russe veut que la france
partent donc il ya un alignement
aujourd'hui d'intérêt qui pourrait mener
à des négociations
j'ai eu l'occasion d'être à nouakchott
la semaine dernière pendant une semaine
il y avait une conférence de paix
africaine et en marge de cette
conférence avait beaucoup de
responsables maliens dont le ministre de
la réconciliation wodié qui fait partie
des cinq colonel putschiste le ministre
des affaires religieuses reconnaît
l'imam dicko avec qui avec lequel je me
suis entretenu pendant plus d'une heure
et demi et j'ai compris vue là
elle les personnages présents et les
personnages qui étaient en marge de
cette de cette réunion donc négociateurs
homme d'état voilà personne influente au
sahel qui a eu une tentative en tout cas
de réactiver des canaux de négociations
directes entre le jeune imam al qaïda et
bamako ne serait ce que pour arriver à
une situation on va dire de de trêve que
la junte pourrait monnayer parce que ça
reste politiquement ça reste ça serait
la dernière carte à jouer pour la jambe
parce qu'une fois le départ des français
acté la situation économique ne va pas
s'améliorer et donc pour contenter la
population aujourd'hui voilà on rentre
en négociations on va avoir une trêve
les gens pourront rentrer chez eux les
routes vont rouvrir surtout ça répond à
une demande malienne qui est de l'époque
du bk et qui était une des conclusions
des assises nationales à l'époque qui
disaient il faut négocier avec iliad
agali et mohamed coup fois qu'ils sont
les représentants d'al qaïda aujourd'hui
au mali donc c'est le seul moyen pour
l'agent de gagner du temps et de rester
au pouvoir c'est le seul moyen de
contenter la population parce que une
fois la séquence départ des français
acte et il faut la donner autre chose à
la population qui soutient la junte
population jeune et c'est donc si les
associations économiques continuent de
se détériorer et la situation
sécuritaire continue de se détériorer ou
de s'aggraver avec le départ les
français il faut mettre tout sur la
table et les négociations pourraient
être une carte maîtresse ou laden ya
quatre maîtresses en tout cas à jouer
pour la junte donc c'est quelque chose à
garder en tête surtout encore une fois
qu'on est dans une situation où les
intérêts plusieurs intérêts
contradictoires il ya encore quelques
mois se rejoignent donc aux dépens de la
france évidemment mais se rejoignent
quand même parce que la france selon
l'ap a dit faisait obstruction à tous
genres la france refuse et même la
dernière tentative de la junte qui que
remonter à quelques semaines maintenant
via le haut conseil islamique a été mise
à mal par parce que la france ne voulait
pas du tout que la junte négocié avec
avec les djihadistes donc c'est quelque
chose à prendre en considération et qui
s'est réellement articulé en tout cas la
semaine dernière à la marge de cette
conférence pour la paix à nouakchott et
qui pourrait être un side effects de ce
départ des forces françaises du mali des
négociations qui avaient déjà eu lieu il
ya déjà des canaux ouverts là on parle
pas de négociation pour otages ces deux
choses il ya négociation pour les bases
d'une saison pour avoir le c sort
legault cessez le feu il ya eu un accord
de cessez-le-feu à niono qui a échoué
finalement donc ce n'est pas une science
exacte et quand on dit à tort quand des
négociations ça va pas dire que la
guerre s'arrête en est d'ailleurs la
proposition de trêve c'était une
proposition d l'imam dicko qui remonte à
début 2009 1 et qui a été reçue
favorablement par les djihadistes d'al
qaïda et qui est resté lettre morte
parce que les conditions n'étaient pas
réunies et la france ne voulait pas donc
aujourd'hui on dans une haie vous
situation évolutive aujourd'hui qui
pourrait mener à ça mais sans oublier
qu'il ya un autre facteur ans qui est
celui le facteur de l'état islamique
présent au mali en guerre alors qu'on
parle actuellement avec al-qaïda à la
population civile en paye le prix il ya
des villages touareg qui ont été vidées
de leur population ces derniers jours
accusé par les seins de soutenir
al-qaïda par les eaux de signal de
taille islamique donc pas question de
négocier avec eux ils veulent pas
négocier il ya eu des novations
ponctuelle on va dire au niger qui ont
totalement échoué mais c'était vraiment
très ponctuel parce que les jadistes
états unis ne veulent pas négocier à un
niveau plus haut que des accords
vraiment le locaux et ponctuel et parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont ils sont ils
sont en faiblesse on va dire au mali
leur vivier ré so tillabéri au niger où
la france est présente je vous rappelle
quand même que après la réunion de pau
le paquet était mis sur la zone des
trois frontières contre l'état islamique
et pas contre al qaïda c'est à dire il
ya deux choses ya le danger sécuritaire
on va dire de l'état islamique qui avale
un bric à sion d'al qaïda et de danger
politique d'al qaîda qui l imbrication
local économique extra et après il faut
voir quelle est la priorité le danger
politique où le danger militaire où le
danger politique qui pourrait devenir
sécuritaire donc c'est une équation qui
n'est pas du tout simple et qui ne sera
pas facilitée en tout cas par le départ
des forces françaises du mali mais en
tout cas c'était inextricable et c'était
déjà acté encore une fois depuis juillet
2021 la france voulait partir suivant ce
même schéma sauf que là ça a été
précipitée c'est pas si général va me
contredire là dessus mais oui tout à
fait non